[Musica]
Allora questa è l'atomo di idrogeno e
l'atomo che ha un incredibile effetto su
tutto l'universo una cosa che uno non si
aspetta appunto controcorrente il centro
dell'atomo di idrogeno ha una particella
che si chiama protone e intorno a
Crotone c'è un'altra particella che si
chiama elettrone il protone è
immensamente più piccolo dell'intero
atomo se fossi in scala vedremo un
puntino invisibile
intorno a Crotone gira l'elettrone che è
una particella molto meno Massiva circa
duemila volte quasi 2000 volte più
leggero del protone e giri in Questa
nuvola enorme un'altra caratteristica
dell'autore in idrogeno che il protone è
una carica elettrica positiva e
l'elettrone ha una carica elettrica
uguale ma disegno opposto queste due
cariche elettriche poste tengono insieme
l'atomo di idrogeno che altrimenti si
respingerebbero
attaccare caratteristica è che ci sono
versioni più pesanti dell'atomo di
idrogeno nel caso ci sia nel nucleo un
neutrone che una particella uguale a
protone Ma che non ha carica elettrica
Oppure ancora più pesante due neutroni
l'altra caratteristica che se il gas di
idrogeno la temperatura normale questo
sistema rimane in questa situazione così
elettricamente neutro Ma se c'è una
grande temperatura del gas si rompe il
legame che c'è tra l'elettrone e il
nucleo dell'atomo e l'atomo di idrogeno
diventa ionizzato in questo caso quando
gas ionizzato
l'idrogeno non reagisce non interagisce
con la luce con la radiazione
elettromagnetica
l'atomo di idrogeno può fare tantissime
cose fantastiche le fai in una maniera
che uno non si aspetta e che vi
racconterò Oggi per esempio
se prendiamo due atomi pesanti di
idrogeno e cerchiamo di metterli insieme
e fonderli generiamo una grandissima
quantità di energia è un'energia pulita
Perché dà come resto un neutrone che è
una particella innocua e un'età atomo
più pesante che è un atomo di Elio Anche
questa è una particella di gas innocua
il problema di fare questa reazione
nucleare e mettere insieme due atomi che
hanno due cariche elettriche positive le
cariche elettriche positive si
respingono e per metterli insieme
bisogna superare una grossa barriera
si riesce a farlo con grandissimi sforzi
oppure facendo una bomba ad idrogeno che
è una cosa che non vogliamo ma se lo
vogliamo fare in maniera pulita e
controllata Bisogna spendere tanta
energia ed è un settore di ricerca che
dura da più di 50 anni e avete sentito
che nel mese di dicembre dell'anno
scorso è stata realizzata per la prima
volta un esperimento che è stato in
grado di fondere questi due atomi di
idrogeno per fare dell'elio in maniera
pulita e controllata
questo è il destino che
impegna tantissimi ricercatori per
produrre energia elettrica in
grandissima quantità senza fare danni in
nessun modo Adesso vi racconto Da dove è
venuto l'idrogeno
l'idrogeno dell'universo Prima di tutto
vi chiedete
Quando è stato creato è stato creato
tutto durante il big bang cioè durante
la creazione dell'universo
quanto ce n'è
tanto
tantissimo e oggi Dove si trova sono
passati quasi 14 miliardi di anni dalla
creazione dell'universo La maggior parte
di questo idrogeno si trova in parte
dentro le stelle attraverso una funzione
lenta dell'atomo di idrogeno come vi ho
fatto vedere prima nel nucleo delle
stelle e in parte si trova nello spazio
che si trova tra le galassie
ora vi dico cosa è successo All'inizio
stiamo parlando dell'origine del Big
Bang cioè del grande scoppio quasi 14
miliardi di anni fa e in particolare che
cosa è successo nei primi 20 minuti di
vita dell'universo tutto quello che noi
vediamo oggi nell'universo è dovuto a
quello che in questi prigionieri
iniziali che hanno caratterizzato questo
universo e in particolare
nel momento T = 0 è un istante di tempo
infinitesimo dopo esisteva un grande un
grande una grande zuppa fatta da il
tempo dalle forze
dallo spazio
dall'energia e dalla materia di tanti
particelle
c'era materia tanta e antimateria tanta
uguale
nello stesso modo dell'esistenza alla
materia materia esistevano in maniera
coesisteva in una specie di equilibrio
cosmico e la materia è uguale
all'antimateria solamente con dei segni
di caratteristiche opposte
un'altra caratteristica del Big Bang
della creazione dell'universo che
all'inizio c'è stata una grande
espansione dell'universo e l'espansione
vuol dire una una decrescita
dell'energia a disposizione un
raffreddamento dell'universo e questo ha
causato
la scomparsa
dell'antimateria e la scomparsa della
materia che si sono annichilite a
vicenda
sono completamente scomparse Perché
l'universo si stava raffreddando perdeva
energia non poteva produrre materia
antimateria che è un processo veramente
che costa tantissime energia e questo è
successo anche alle particelle che si
sono formate per esempio ai protoni agli
antiprotoni ai neutroni e gli anti
neutroni le particelle più stabili che
esistono nell'universo di alloro sono
passati circa 10 microsecondi
dall'inizio dell'universo e si stanno
protoni antiprotoni l'universo si
raffredda
si espande scompare anche
scompaiono anche tutti i protoni e tutti
gli antiprotoni i neutroni degli anti
neutroni quello che rimane è solamente
un resto
di materia Rispetto all'antimateria
perché all'inizio dell'universo Viene
creato un pochino più di materia
rispetto all'antimateria quel piccolo
resto rimane nell'universo Noi siamo
fatti di tutti quanti noi siamo fatti di
questo resto di materia rispetto
all'antimateria
quindi esistono questo piccolo eccesso
di protoni e di neutroni e a un
centesimo di vita dall'universo
l'universo è ancora abbastanza caldo
si è raffreddato tanto però ma ancora
una temperatura che è circa un miliardo
di gradi è ancora abbastanza caldo per
innescare
a 10 secondi di vita dall'universo 10
secondi le prime fusioni nucleari che
coinvolgono il protone e neutroni
e creare i primi elementi chimici
leggeri dell'universo
l'universo continua ad espandersi si
raffredda a 20 minuti di vita è troppo
freddo relativamente parlando
per avere ancora funzioni nucleari e
quindi a 20 minuti di vita dall'universo
la chimica dell'universo degli atomi è
fissa si congela ed è 78% idrogeno 22%
Elio e tutto il resto sono tracce di
litio
quell'elemento chimico che è dentro le
batterie dei vostri cellulari a questo
punto
questi meccanismi di fusione nucleari
nell'universo si fermano
ora facciamo un grande passo in avanti
nel tempo e nello spazio l'universo
continua a espandersi continua a
raffreddarsi si raffredda tantissimo e
l'unica forza che domina in questo caso
è la forza di gravità e quello che la
forza che ci tiene piantati sulla terra
la forza di gravità costringe a gli
atomi a mettersi insieme fare cose
sempre più dense più calde il gas si
riscalda si accendono le stelle le prime
stelle le prime galassie i primi buchi
neri
e sono passati circa 400 milioni di anni
dal Big Bang abbiamo fatto un
grandissimo passo in avanti
facciamo un altro balzo in avanti
e guardiamo come è fatto l'universo
qualche miliardo di anni dopo
qui succede che l'universo è molto
grande sei molto raffreddato è diventato
molto buio Ci sono delle stelle ci sono
delle galassie ci sono i buchi neri ma
insieme i buchi neri si formano degli
oggetti particolarmente brillanti che
cambieranno la storia della mia vita io
studiavo in questa università volevo
fare la scienziata volevo studiare
all'università
e mi viene proposto una cosa che magari
nessuno farebbe c'è studiare
queste sorgenti molto luminose queste
sorgenti si chiamano Quasar i Quasar
sono gli oggetti tra i più brillanti che
esistono nell'universo
che sono così brillanti perché al centro
dei Quasar ci sono dei buchi neri molto
pesanti Questo è un controsenso non si
aspetterebbe che i buchi neri siano in
grado di generare così tanta luce in
realtà quello che succede in queste in
questi buchi neri che c'è così tanta
forza di gravità che il gas che gli
muove intorno che è fatto di idrogeno di
Elio deve muoversi molto velocemente per
non precipitare al centro del buco nero
e questo riscalda tantissimo il gas lo
fa diventare molto luminoso
questi oggetti Qui si possono studiare
anche per guardare
il buio che c'è intorno perché sono così
luminosi che illuminano l'universo
intorno e quello che ho fatto io quando
ho deciso di iniziare questa carriera di
ricerca nel campo dell'astrofisica
ma è una cosa veramente che uno non si
aspetta cosa succede cosa ho fatto cosa
ha fatto per tanto tempo guardo un
Quasar E mi rendo ci rendiamo conto che
guardando questo qua sarà da terra
ci sono tantissime nubi di gas fatte di
idrogeno che circondano lo spazio vuoto
che non è affatto vuoto e non è affatto
vuoto e inesistente e lo guardiamo da
terra prendiamo un telescopio e
guardiamo la luce del quadro questa luce
del Quasar viene assorbita da queste
nubi di gas che si trovano nello spazio
intergalattico tra le galassie cosa ci
rivelano queste queste osservazioni
quello che si vede nella pratica è uno
spettro fatto così cioè l'intensità
della luce del Quasar in funzione della
lunghezza d'onda
lo vediamo tantissime righe di
assorbimento queste righe di
assorbimento sono tutte ognuna collegata
a una nube di gas di idrogeno che si
trova tra il Quasar e noi e ce ne sono
tantissime Questo è un piccolo pezzetto
e ci mostrano che il gas è
sostanzialmente molto rarefatto
è molto ionizzato
una sola particella su 10.000 di queste
atomi di idrogeno e gas neutro e sono
queste particelle neutre che assorbono
la luce e che si mostrano in questo modo
queste righe di assorbimento che queste
nubi di gas sono enormi
sono grandi come una galassia o anche
più e ce ne sono tantissime sparse nello
spazio tra il quasi per noi e questa è
una conferma che il modello del Big Bang
che dice che all'inizio l'universo Era
molto piccolo caldo e denso si è espanso
tantissimo e confermato da uno spettro
come questo
una cosa che veramente incredibile da
studiare Cioè questo ci dimostra che il
vuoto Non è vuoto che è pieno di nubi e
che gli atomi creati durante il Big Bang
di idrogeni di Elio sono sostanzialmente
dentro questo gas il gas e lo spazio del
nulla
e noi capiamo adesso come è fatto
l'universo attraverso questi studi
oggi l'universo è molto più ingrandito
sono passati quasi 14 miliardi di anni e
possiamo studiare quanto è denso
l'universo la densità media
dell'universo
è un atomo in media ogni 4 metri cubi di
spazio
più vuoto di così non può essere non
riuscirete mai a ottenere un vuoto così
spinto in laboratorio mai impossibile
ma la cosa più incredibile che lo spazio
non è riempito per la maggior parte di
idrogeno C'è materia che 5 volte più
pesante
in materia che non è fatta di atomi il
materiale che non si riesce a capire di
che cosa sia fatto è materia che domina
su tutta la materia che esiste
nell'universo non assorbe luce non
emette luce è impossibile da studiare e
di natura ignota e l'abbiamo chiamata
materia oscura
Come facciamo a sapere che esiste la
materia oscura se di questa materia
oscura non sappiamo niente
ancora una volta ce lo dice l'idrogeno
E come si fa torniamo all'atomo di
idrogeno e torniamo a parlare di
qualcosa di veramente misterioso e che
un fenomeno molto raro per succedere ma
succede nell'atomo di idrogeno un'altra
proprietà di queste particelle della
tomo di idrogeno è che hanno una
rotazione che si chiama spin Ma questa
rotazione Non può essere qualsiasi cosa
per esempio se il protone ruota in
questa direzione quindi lo spin E questa
freccia in alto
l'elettrone può avere una rotazione
uguale parallela nella stessa direzione
oppure in direzione opposta
nient'altro è permesso
nella fisica microscopica dell'atomo di
idrogeno sono solamente queste le due
possibilità delle rotazioni di queste
due particelle in questo caso si parla
di questo legame che tecnicamente si
chiama entanglement
la l'altra situazione in cui
l'elettrone gira in maniera opposta
parallela ma in direzione opposta e una
situazione che ha leggermente meno
energia di questa situazione qui in cui
due i due spin sono nella stessa
direzione
l'universo tende a passare da una
situazione dove c'è più energia a una
situazione dove c'è meno energia
Ma nella fisica classica
questo questa transizione non avviene è
considerata una transizione proibita
quindi il laboratorio questo non avviene
se un atomo di idrogeno ha una
configurazione con gli spin paralleli
non cambierà e non passerà una
situazione di meno energia
Ma nella fisica dell'universo in realtà
questo processo avviene e quando avviene
viene messo una piccola quantità di
energia che la differenza di energia tra
i due stati E questa piccola differenza
di energia un'onda radio di 1.420
megahertz
Allora cosa c'è qua dentro come facciamo
da questo a capire che nell'universo
siamo per 5 volte dominato dalla materia
oscura
una cosa incredibile È un processo
rarissimo questo che avviene avviene ma
molto raramente in un atomo di idrogeno
neutro anche quello è molto raro in un
universo che è praticamente vuoto
ma una cosa incredibile
gli strumenti la tecnologia la mente
umana è riuscita a trovare anche questo
non sappiamo che cos'è la materia oscura
ma sappiamo che c'è come si fa
guardiamo una galassia una galassia
normale fatta di stelle qui questa
luminosità è dovuta alla presenza di
stelle le stelle che bruciano idrogeno
nelle loro nucleo e sono diventate
luminose
questo è un'immagine fatta con un
telescopio ottico ma se guardiamo la
stessa Galassia con un con delle antenne
radio
calibrate nella frequenza giusta
lunghezza di tenuta giusta vediamo che
la galassia è molto più grande che di
quello che ci mostrano le stelle
stiamo guardando questa transizione
dell'atomo di idrogeno da una situazione
all'altra che emette onde radio una
frequenza precisa un segnale molto
debole che mi mostra che la galassia è
enorme
Ma questo non mi dice che c'è la materia
oscura dice che c'è molto gas vero molto
rarefatto vero ma la materia oscura
cos'è che ce lo dice è sempre l'idrogeno
perché ruota la galassia ruota e ruota
molto veloce e cosa fa Ruotare la
galassia e la forza di gravità non c'è
nient'altro forza in queste scale
grandissime perché ruota così
velocemente perché deve combattere la
forza di gravità altrimenti
collasserebbe su se stessa
e se ruota così velocemente perché c'è
una grande quantità di materia che non
si vede 5 volte meglio di più di quello
che c'è nelle stelle nel gas e per
questo che sappiamo che siamo dominati
da questa materia misteriosa
torniamo alle stelle
abbiamo detto che le stelle sono
luminose perché nel loro nucleo fondono
Elio per fare
fondano idrogeno per fare Elio questo è
necessario perché ancora una volta devo
combattere la forza di gravità
che mi farebbe collassare la stella su
se stessa ma dentro il nucleo della
stella le temperature i gas molto
compresso
si riesce a superare quella barriera
elettrostatica tra cariche elettriche
uguali per fare la fusione dell'idrogeno
ma è questo avviene ancora una volta in
maniera inaspettata controcorrente
Appunto
le temperature per esempio nel sole sono
dell'ordine di 15 milioni di gradi sono
temperature troppo basse
il core delle Stelle per la maggior
parte sono sono stelle fredde
cosa succede Allora prima di tutto
Diciamo che la fusione dell'idrogeno
avviene nel 90% delle stelle della
galassia
l'altro 10% sono funzioni nucleari di
altro tipo la maggior parte quindi delle
stelle si mantiene in equilibrio perché
si riesce a fondere l'idrogeno un
processo di fusione molto efficiente ma
la temperatura è troppo bassa Come si
riesce a fare questa fusione
c'è un altro meccanismo misterioso
stupendo
che nel mondo normale non avviene Ma che
nel mondo microscopico dell'idrogeno
avviene raramente ma avviene
e come giocare i dadi Come diceva il mio
predecessore
immaginate per esempio di avere una
scala macroscopica Questo è il monte
Everest
voi volete superare il Monte Everest
questa bambina vuole superare il Monte
Everest in un balzo e inizia a saltare
salta salta per tanto tempo milioni di
volte miliardi di volte non riesce a
superare il Monte Everest Finché la
miliardesima e uno volta dopo il primo
salto all'improvviso si trova dall'altra
parte questo si chiama effetto tunnel e
che l'effetto che avviene nelle stelle
oggi per fondere l'idrogeno un
meccanismo totalmente improbabile Ma nel
mondo microscopico dell'idrogeno avviene
una volta ogni tanto e abbastanza per
mantenere le stelle calde e vincere la
forza di gravità e tenere in equilibrio
per miliardi di anni
quanto durerà l'idrogeno
ce n'è tantissimo è stato creato tutto
durante il big bang ed è consumato nelle
stelle
però le stelle nella galassia nelle
galassie di tutto l'universo sono per la
maggior parte delle nane Questa è
Proxima Centauri e la stella più vicina
al sole 4
anni luce di distanza 40.000 miliardi di
chilometri
la massa di questa Stella è 30 30% la
massa del sole è una stella nana
le stelle nane sono la maggior parte
delle stelle nella galassia queste
stelle consumano idrogeno Come fa il
sole e come fa la maggior parte delle
stelle Ma perché sono molto leggere
relativamente parlando riescono a
resistere contro la gravità per molto
tempo
stelle così bruceranno idrogeno per
centinaia di miliardi di anni
l'universo oggi ha quasi 14 miliardi di
anni
E questa resisteranno per centinaia di
miliardi di anni
quando l'universo sarà diventato gigante
rispetto a come adesso e sarà diventato
sempre più vuoto sempre più freddo
è un viaggio lunghissimo il nostro e
durerà tantissimo tempo Però torniamo a
casa e concludo con il sole
Questa è la nostra Stella è una stella
normale gialla brucia Elio idrogeno il
nucleo per fare Elio
dallo studio dell'atmosfera della stella
del Sole riusciamo a capire qual è la
composizione chimica del Sole e delle
stelle che ci sono nella galassia e in
molte galassie Oggi
siamo partiti da 20 minuti dopo il big
bang con un universo fatto da 70 per 78%
di idrogeno 22% di Elio e tracce di
litio e oggi dopo 14 miliardi di anni di
bruciamento di idrogeno siamo in questa
situazione qua
75% idrogeno
24% e io tutto il resto tutti gli altri
elementi chimici
1.4%. Questo è quello che ha consumato
lì l'universo in quasi 14 miliardi di
anni
capite quanto sia efficiente questo
processo di fusione dell'idrogeno e
Credetemi che un giorno l'idrogeno
risolverà per sempre in maniera pulita
il problema della crisi energetica sulla
terra e della problema climatico Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
cita speranza con questa sua
affermazione conclusi